bonsoir ran ver vous êtes pédicure
podologue présent ce soir pour nous
parler de nos pieds 11e journée
nationale de dépistage et de prévention
pour la santé des pieds le 23 mai et
c'est très sérieux 67 % des Français
souffrent de leur pieds 35 % des
Français ont des mots et des pathologies
qui nécessitent impérativement la
consultation d'un podologue c'est bien
ça c'est des chiffres assez effarants
mais c'est la réalité des choses et très
peu de de de personnes consultent et
comment ça s'explique ces mauvais
chiffres alors d'une part par une
mauvaise communication par rapport à la
profession d'autre part une
méconnaissance de notre profession
autant par rapport au patients et au
corps médical beaucoup de médecins ne
savent pas exactement quel est notre
rôle quel est notre métier beaucoup nous
estiment entre nous appelle un peu des
gratteurs de pieds alors c'est pas du
tout le cas il y a toute la partie
pédicurie et podologie euh il y a pas
mal d'appareillages qui sont mis en
place pour les déformations d'orteil les
orthoplasties déformation angu donc de
l'ongle des apparillages pour pour les
déformations de l'ongle on a aussi la
partie semelle qui est plus connu aussi
hein et on a on a souvent la
dissociation pédicure podologue alors
que c'est vraiment la même chose c'est
le même praticien et euh donc il faut
communiquer par rapport à ça et c'est le
but de la journée qui est mise en place
de 11e journée nationale de dépistage ce
sera demain c'est organisé par l'Union
française pour la santé et du pied 200
lieu public en France il participe des
centres d'examen des mutualités sociales
agricoes également ou encore des mutuels
des centres sociaux municipaux vous vous
allez organiser votre mobilisation dans
les ivelines sur la commune d'Issou à
partir de 15h ça va s'organiser comment
ce sera à la salle des fêtes Maurice
Ravel pour ceux qui veulent s'y rendre
alors ça s'organise donc on sera
plusieurs podologues donc pédicure
podolog euh on reçoit les patients donc
sans rendez-vous c'est gratuit euh on va
mettre en place une projection d'un film
qui a été tourné avec comment dire des
expressions de de différents passants
qui ont été pris dans la rue euh il y a
notre président aussi Jam Wabi qui
intervient dans ce dans ce film donc
déjà il y aura toute une partie
d'information par rapport à ça et
ensuite on reçoit également donc le
public pour des examens gratuit donc de
prévention et de dépistage donc le but
c'est véritablement de procéder à
quelques dépistages de permettre à des
gens qui ne vont jamais consulter
d'avoir quelques indications sur l'état
de santé de leurs pied ça cible un
public peut-être aussi particulier sur
lequel il faut être vigilant femmes
enceintes adolescents également Phe de
croissance les enfants oui alors c'est
finalement ça touche tous les âges de la
vie puisquon démarre à l'enfant à partir
de 4 ans la consultation chez un
podologue pas avant pas avant 4 ans
avant sauf s'il y a des grosses
déformations à noter euh mais en général
on renvoie plutôt sur des orthopédistes
mais si vous notez que votre enfant a
des déformations importantes au niveau
du pied qu' a les genoux qui se touchent
qui chutent régulièrement on peut
consulter mais c'est vrai que
l'appareillage au niveau des semelles
orthopédiques n'a n'intervient pas avant
l'âge de 4 ans quelles sont les
conséquences justement de pour une
personne qui ne ferait pas assez
attention et qui aurait des des
pathologies alors par exemple le le
schéma le le plus important par exle
c'est sur le diabétique le le diabétique
qui prend pas soin de ses pieds qui ne
régule pas son diabète qui ne voit pas
un diabétologue qui ne surveille pas ses
pieds euh on peut très vite avoir des
ples qui ne cicatrisent pas du fait
d'une neuropathie d'une artériopathie
c'est-à-dire une perte de sensibilité au
niveau du pied et des problèmes de
circulation au niveau des des artères du
pied qui engendre un retard de
cicatrisation et donc au final on peut
arriver sur des emputation il y en a des
milliers encore aujourd'hui en France et
c'est un grave santé de un grave
problème de santé publique depuis 2008
l'assurance maladie rembourse les bilans
et soins podologiqu des diabétiques dont
les risques de complications sont sont
les plus graves au-delà de C cette
partie particulire de la population
est-ce que c'est remboursé combien ça
coûte une consultation chez un podologue
alors en moyenne un se pédicuré il y a
une qui a été faite tourne aux alentours
de 30 € malheureusement assurance
maladie on peut quasiment dire qu'elle
ne rembourse pas puisque c'est à hauteur
d' 1,26 voilàre ça aussi qui explique
que les consultations ça mais il y a les
patients qui ignorent très souvent même
des patients qui viennent consulter
depuis des plusieurs années qui ignorent
que leur mutuel prennent en charge des
soins de 3 à 5 par an des fois en
totalité et alors ensuite lorsqu'il y a
cette consultation que les gens ENF fait
le le déplacement vous intervenez de
quelle manière sur la la journée pas sur
la journée mais sur des des gens qui
auraient des des problèmes de pied qui
pourraient ensuite entraîner des
problèmes de dos ou comment vous pouvez
intervenir alors on intervient donc
d'une part par le soin pédicural
pédicurie où on intervient au niveau de
la peau et des ongles ensuite on a la
partie podologique où là on examine le
patient donc on fait un examen clinique
complet en statique en dynamique en
charge et en décharge on analyse
également on a des outils informatiques
très performants de nos jours des
plformme baropodométrique qui nous
permett d'analyser les les différentes
pressions au niveau du pied on utilise
aussi la l'analyse dynamique avec des
tapis de course et des des caméras donc
ça permet d'avoir un examen complet de
la posture du patient et d'adapter
l'appareillage donc la semelle en
fonction du pied du patient et aussi de
de ses chaussures et audelà de ça il y a
peut-être des bons réflexes à avoir
quelques conseils à donner il faut bien
choisir ses chaussures par exemple bien
choisir ses chaussures adapter son
activité sportive consulter un podologue
si nécessaire un kiné un ostéopathe
c'est vraiment un cercle entre
paramédicaux et médicaux qui est très
important et c'est là-dessus qu'on
essaie de communiquer au mieux au jour
d'aujourd'hui 23 mai 11e journée
nationale de dépistage donc de
prévention autour de la santé du pied
avec 10 éditions Derrière vous ça s'est
plutôt bien passé quel bilan vous en
faites il y a une augmentation ensuite
des fréquentations globalement il y a
une augmentation donc la première
journée du du pied qui qui a eu lieu
donc en en 2003 a très bien fonctionné
depuis ça continue et ça ne fait
qu'augmenter on a de plus en plus de
sites on a des sites publics mais aussi
en école et en entreprise qui inter on
intervient aussi en dehors de cette
journée du pied dans les écoles
justement pour prendre les pathologies
le plus tôt possible 11e journée
nationale dans les ivelines ce sera du
côté de Issou rendez-vous dès 15h merci
à vous pour ces précisions